so you you said this a while back some
people just need to find a path to being
comfortable with themselves enough that
they can be comfortable with people
around I love this quote because I think
that's so true until you're comfortable
with yourself and in your own skin how
first of all can anybody else be
comfortable with you and then also it's
reciprocal I love this why why do you
think this I think it's so real that
anytime somebody has a weird
relationship to your specificities for
me it's so frequently being gay and very
fat and it's like that's not about me
that's about them you know it's about
their issues with themselves and I I
think that one of the best things we can
do for other people is respect ourselves
and our own specificities enough to be
able to respect theirs and that's really
what this movie Bros is about is like
two white CIS gay guys who have
developed like protective mechanisms for
dealing with a homophobic world who
don't realize how much those protective
mechanisms are hurting themselves and
the people around them and then learning
to like chill out and have fun and be
comfortable with themselves yeah but
also as I was saying before Kelly I have
to tell you okay thank you so much for
how much you have taken care of me on
dance floors so many times in my life
when I needed you you showed up
where you're going to love the next
album
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody